x plus 4 divided by x plus 1 is correct. For the first numerator, we find the
factors of 12 that sum to positive 7, which are positive 3 and positive 4. For
the second numerator, we find the factors of positive 4 that add to negative 5.
These are negative 4 and negative 1. Notice that the a coefficient in front of
the x squared term is 1 in every single quadratic. This means that we can just
use the factors we find of 12 That summed to 7 in our binomials. The same was
true here, we used the factors of positive four that sum to negative five and
four in our binomials. These are the factors for our other denominators and now
we're ready to simplify. X plus 3 divided by x plus 3 equals 1. And x minus 4
divided by x minus 4 Also equals 1. The last equivalence of 1 is x minus 1 and x
minus 1. Remember that these factors don't dis, disappear, they really equal 1.
So we multiply 1 times x plus 4 and one's times x plus 1. Any times anything is
itself. So we're left with x plus 4 divided by the quantity x plus 1.